hi everyone welcome to today's webinar
called discovery and verification of
eqtls associated with lung
adenocarcinoma my name is Jeffrey
Cassell and I'm a senior market
development manager in the genetic
Sciences Division at Thermo Fisher
Scientific I'll be your modern your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by thermo
Fisher Scientific the world's leader in
serving science our mission is to enable
our customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer to learn
more please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located to the far left of
your screen today's presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits so now I want to present
today's speakers Tommaso Giovanni who is
the former director of the Research Unit
genetic epidemiology and
pharmacogenomics at the National
Institute at the National tumor
Institute of Milan and dr. harita Bruce
Lingam senior product application
scientist a thermo Fisher Scientific for
complete biographies on the speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top right of your screen
so dr. George Ani may now begin your
presentation you know and the muzzle dry
Ronnie and I will talk about the
collaboration that we have carried out
with the demo CCS and typical the
discovery and verification of expression
quantitative trait low sign in lambda t
show blank adenocarcinoma patient
in life - its summarized the aim of
these studies so the aim was to identify
the equity ELLs and the particular
equity years acting in cheese and
equally as acting in France so which is
acting political years are equally as
affecting the expression of nearby genes
where Santa equal years are the equity
as affecting the expression of distant
target genes
what about the importance of the
analysis of equity else in London the
Sonoma and how we are the screen the end
discover the the equity ELLs and our
verified the equity answered by an
independent study and also will show you
the solutions that are divided into
certain scientific and at the end the
questions and answer
life for it should be personalized ow we
have carried out this study so we have
measured the expression levels of all
known genes so we have read out all
transcriptome analysis and these other
phenotypes of our time then we have also
carried out genome-wide and I think and
then we put together the fellow title
with the genotype in other words we are
carried out political analysis of the
association's
genotype phenotype pieces for each
asleep and for each target gene so it
was a matrix analysis and originality
we have also used the coverage that may
affect the transcription levels of Jesus
or such sex ages looking ahead
you
like you can see how equalizer works you
know what that conditions the
prescription partisan bind to some kill
vigils and motivated the expression of
target genes so they may an actor in on
different genes in your genome or may
act on a single gene so the painter on
the very type of transcription factors
light six it's shown that we can ever
so-called cheese equally and so they
could be s acting inches suspecting the
expression levels of associated genes
over over nearby genes so this could be
a tarpon yes located usually in the
promoter region or region close to the
motor regional of a given gene and this
way a polymer is named modulate the
affinity over the transcript apart order
with the targeted DNA region modulating
between expressions in this case may
alter the expression of a target eg
in his life that seven we can see in
what are the trans equal yet so these
are genetically models affecting the
expression of target genes located on
different chromosomes or different
region of the same a chromosome in this
case we have a de credit evaluation not
in the promoter region of a giving in
but we have a genetically more teens in
the advance the transcript top part of
the gene model coding for de tráfico
part in the this way we can have
[Music]
prescription bottles with difference in
the protein structure and so the
different types of transcription factors
depending on the needs they may have a
different affinity for the binding
region and in this way can effectively
expression of God architecture or target
genes so that may be located on
different chromosomes so it may be the
plants were in could hear me effectively
expression of multiple genes if the
description factors it's a description
platform of leading multiple genes
you
light eater who ever pictured a
Schindler from the work of McKinney
total network genetics in which I was
published in 2017 this is a YouTube
Walker that has carried out by a
consultant working on the genetics of
lung cancer and as you can see there are
many Masai affecting the risk of lung
cancer the lung cancer not considering
the different Institute's there are this
18 low side statistically significant
age my and for longer notice we know
model are April sigh most of these cases
the function of this loss is not known
in other words the mechanism how this
genetic form of inter located in the
junk mini
affect their individual risk of lung
cancer is not known so the equity
analysis from a data center we to
identify possible mood of actions of
Josiah affecting the risk of disease and
also not only hysteresis we can also
study those I affecting the outcome of
disease and injury we are looking at
also affecting the overall survival over
land and investigation
slide nine that the table summarizes the
our previous results on analysis of
equity years in Rose I already met
association with the risk of lung cancer
the founder locus on chromosome 15 in
the nicotinic receptor la casa and in
this local sermon we found several
promotions affecting the expression of
higher to gene and of yes ma for jill
the two genes located in the same local
Saudis are kiss acting equal years and
also we found another equity L affecting
the expression of ers one managing it's
on chromosome 1 and 19
so lights time some I the water will
sing so that many needs are associated I
have been found associated with the risk
of disease in particular lung cancer and
but also with other cancers and also
with other diseases and a moment we do
not know the mechanism underlying these
disassociation so they need a functional
characterization and the result from
genome-wide Association studies a trait
that 90% of all of hola needs next to no
coding regions also two regions that may
acted by regulating expression of our
target gene so the modulation of
expression of target genes may represent
a potent mechanism underlying the visual
difference in risk of disease and so
they are both of these studies
and the police reasons could yet become
important in understanding the neural
mechanism of diseases in the industry
preliminary study we carried out the
analysis of the old gnome to assess
asleep function as equal year in the
lambda short series of 93 Italian
language and carcinoma patients
statically treated in the hospital
collaborating to our study where all
these hospitals are and research
institutes are located in the a million
area
on slide 11 and it to summarize the the
work law of the study on the top line
you can see how we have carried out the
analysis of genetic polymorphisms on
your genome well on the bottom line you
can see how we ever carried out the
analysis of Krakatau and then here we
have a mesh the result of both gel
typing and transcriptome analysis to
identify equity else and then we have
carried out the technical validation of
the equity arranging a different
technical approach
on light Iowa is the description of
other samples that we used there are 93
a London carcinoma patients surgically
treated and they are typical patients
where their characteristics are typical
of this type of patients so they are
quite old
the median age is 17 year old and in
this case we have quite a good quasi
same distribution between the enemies
and males and also we have patients with
the different pathological stage and the
difference is moving a bit
like you Tina you can see there is a
[Music]
whole picture of a bracket um desaad in
this cases where there are with selected
only the 1000 genes where we have seen
the most evaluation in gene expression
so these are the most informative genes
and we can see in each column is a
single patient so you can see that there
is some difference among groups of
patients and over all other this is a
typical pattern of such kind of study
here is a example of genotyping of a
sneaker
as you can see there are different
genotypes we have individual remote i/o
support given allele from diverse
apparel deal and in the middle we have
adult diapers patient carrying a local
needs
and as light 15-hour we have reported
the series of mixer associated them with
the modulation of expression level of
target genes for the statistical
analysis we have used the genotype as an
integral number it means that we have
used in zero one or two coats
genotype depending on the number of the
minor allele for each Smith
and for the statistical analysis we have
also adjusted the for a multiple testing
and so we have derived the year values
that indicator it for the Association
was statistically significant or not
doctor correction for multiple
convention
and of
like 16 16 you can see a circle plot
room as an example of the eqtl that we
have identified in the present study and
when you see a line on the same
chromosome it means that the ticket yet
here is a cookie that was mapped in that
religion is agent acting equity air so
it acts on the same chromosome well when
you see a circular going from one
chromosome o to another one is indicate
a transacting equity L you can see that
there are a few grants acting equity L
mapping the expression of genes located
in other chromosomes and most of the as
Nitsa where she's acting equity ads
then on like 17 and you can also an
example over the expression level of by
genotype of the genes that we have
identified in the present studies and at
target of equity and regions so most of
the cases we have quite dose-response
relationship between the genotype and
phenotype in other words by increasing
the number of minority do we have any
research on the expression level of a
given gene or a degree so it depends on
the type of Association that we have
identified
you
so whether we can go on a slide 18 and
we are Rita and talk about on the
verification of microarray data using
quantitative PCR
all right thank you so much dr. Giovanni
for that really nice introduction and
status of the project till screening
discovery so as dr. Joe Ghani mentioned
the next stage of the project was to
verify data from microarrays and
internal analysis using qPCR for this we
choose to use the TaqMan acid attachment
methods we used to verify genotypic
genotyping results from the axiom arrays
and these were a natural choice the
confirmation because you know the as
provide ease on axiom arrays are already
matched to TaqMan genotyping acid using
the RFID links so post eqtl analysis
nests with interest from axiom erease
can be identified by verification
studies and since providers as I said
were already matched at Manassas a
simple click of button on the axiom
analysis suite take you to the TaqMan
snap asses on the Tasman add thermo
Fisher search portal and these can be
automatically added to cart and ordered
and the image on the slide shows you
exactly how that's done so on the Left
panel you see a screenshot of the axiom
analysis suite with provide ease of
associated to our SIDS these are SIDS as
I mentioned our internal link to TaqMan
snip asses of the click on our IDs will
automatically take you to the Tasman
snip of ordering page
similarly the provide ease and help
transcript crafter IDs on Clarion D
which is a gene expression array are
also matched to tack man gene expression
a scene in this case however you would
need to use the provided at the actual
ID or the transfer ID as such search
input and search for pac-man gene
expression acids in the thermo Fisher
attachment search portal once is done on
the portal of
results in several different Chapman
gene expression assays which would then
be ordered for verification studies so
that's a quick overview of how we chose
the TaqMan acids in the next few slides
I'm going to talk about some of the data
that we obtained so for the genotyping
data verification area as I said we use
the black material genotyping asses
these asses were run on applied by
system via 7 real-time qPCR on
instrument however these assays could be
done with any of the compatible qPCR
instruments and genotyping calls for
this set of data were made on thermo
Fisher connect GT app on the left you
see an example of the plaster clock
showing allelic discrimination for step
RS 5 5 8 2 3 8 4 4 in the plot each of
the homozygous alleles are represented
by a either a red dot which is the GG in
this example our blue again in this
example is for the homozygous a a allele
and the heterocycles alleles are in
green
samples that did not amplify are
highlighted by yellow rain
gene expression on NASA's life
genotyping assays were run on applied
Biosystems via seven real-time qpcr
instrument and data was also analyzed on
primo Fisher connect the sign the RQ or
relative quantification app on the left
you see multi-component plots of
amplification curves for gene x RR a1
again this is an example of how the
amplification leader looks with a tap
mention expression acid super both of
genotyping and gene expression analysis
we found that the of data from TAC
Manassas had a very good concordance to
of data on the expression and genotyping
arrays
once we had genotyping and gene
expression answers revulsion them we
combined the data using jump software
version 13 efficiency in the graphs here
expression signals when categorised by
genotype calls shoot the same pattern as
seen in microarrays the genes GBP 3 and
lr r CL r r c 3 on the left panel our
data from qPCR and the run on the right
you see data from microarrays the two
platforms results in images that look
like mirror images because expression
signal on microarray platforms are
reported out as signal intensities
whereas signal from qPCR are reported in
the form of C cues where expression
signals are lower CQ risk response to a
higher expression value so although the
data is a very similar on the both on
the two platforms the images appear or
the plots appear as bigger images
and the other set of data was for genes
x RR a1 and RBM 12 again we found that
data between two PCR and microarray
responded really well thereby conforming
microarray data by two VCR so these are
the four each appears that we were able
to confirm by QB Xie although although
there were a few others that were
identified in our discovery with
microarrays because of the small sample
size we were not able to statistically
confirm or have statistically valid data
to confirm with qpcr our thinking is
that if we had a larger cohort of
samples we were eight we would be able
to confirm more of the each videos that
identified by microwave with kabisa and
that is really the end of the data I did
want to take this time to quickly go
over the workflow so I'm gonna jump back
to slide 11 that was presented by dr.
tehrany
to kind of bring everything together
with respect to the workflow once we
have the sample DNA and RNA was
extracted from the same sample and
imperil DNA and RNA were processed on
either of the axiom of PM ra arrays for
genotyping or the clarium d arrays
protein expression as can be seen by the
flow chart data from axiom arrays which
is then processed on axiom analysis
suite and data from Cleary MD and
theories which is then processed on the
tap 4.0 software was used to feed into
the eqtl analysis matrix each UCL all
package where which has been identifying
putative QTL these fugitives eqtls for
the confirm
by the applied Biosystems attachments
snipped genotyping acids and tacna and
gene expression acid less is our entire
work so I want to take another minute or
so to just go into some of the details
of the platform's Thermo Fisher
Scientific offers an entire and the
entire solution for you
starting from microwaves both gene
expression and genotyping arrays which
were used for screening and discovery in
the study major a matrix e qtn our
packages a third-party software which
can be used for identifying each eqtl
and then we also offer TaqMan gene
expression and sniff a phase which we in
this study used for conformational
studies with that this is the end of my
slides and we'll open up for questions
from you
okay thank you so much for Rita thank
you so much to Maz oh that was a really
great informative presentation so now
let's start with the live Q&A portion
for this webinar and if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll go ahead and answer as many of
the questions as we have time forms and
we actually do already have some
questions so I'll go ahead and kick it
off here with the first one so the first
question is why did you choose to use
micro arrays instead of next-gen
sequencing for the gene expression
profiling experiment
you
um so I can take that of dr. Ronnie you
don't mind if I understand right
dr. Ronnie's lab had used NGS to profile
the transcriptome in the past and when
they found out about the clarium D
arrays and that they offer complete
transcriptome coverage they chose to use
that because you know it was a good
alternative to using 9 GS
okay great great thank you so much for
that harita I think maybe this next
question is for Tommaso why was your
study cohort only 93 samples is that not
too small for an EQ TL study well this
was a preliminary study so we have used
the such number of samples it's the most
convenient we can put all the samples in
the same plate and this way we can
analyze the good Union and our needs
quite easily in the same sample sir and
it was also time effective study this
way we received the disaster in
relatively short time and but the study
it's relatively small but it's quite
informative as you have seen we detected
many could be a statistically
significant equity L by within a wide
analysis and so although all the
studying a the size of the study may be
increased it was sufficient as a proof
of concept to show that such approach
could be a cost-effective and time
effective for rapid analysis of the
equity years in a tissue of interest
okay thank you so much for that answer
not explanation let's see we have
another question in here and are all of
this significant eqtls sis eqtls or did
you also find any trans eqtl in your
study and we have detected the both
trees acting and the trans acting the
equity as most of the equity asset we
have detected are a choose acting equity
s but we were able to detect also or
several transacting you could years
acting on multiple target genes located
in different chromosomes
okay thank you thank you dr. Giordani it
looks like the next question might also
be for you what was the minor allele
cutoff used in your study and why in
this study we decided to use a cut-off
of 0.1 it means a 10% as the frequency
of the minor allele and then the reason
for such a choice was selected a Nam the
size of the studies is the relatively
small so we had the 93 samples and to
get the some significant Association and
we needed at least a group of patients
we carried a minor allele so in this way
we we analyzed the most informative that
means this is why we have chosen the 0.1
as a minority sequencing but if we
carried out we carried out the largest
study I mean in 1,000 times or so we can
use a lower total for the minor allele
at people
gotcha okay thank you thank you so much
for that it looks like the next question
we have is for her Rita so how many
samples do you think need to be
confirmed by real-time PCR that's a good
question so as as I had mentioned you
know we expect to at least verify a
couple of hundred different samples to
be able to confirm data but just to add
on to what dr. Ghani said is this was a
preliminary test this was a preliminary
study and with limited number of samples
so every sample that was status test for
microwave was also tested for qPCR but
in a larger study um you know the
thousands of samples are being tested on
microwave a couple of hundred about two
or three different hundred samples could
be tested for qPCR verification
okay okay thank you so much let's see it
looks like we've got a lot of questions
here but it looks like we have time to
do one more and in harita this is a I
think that's similar questions so maybe
let's see if you can take this one why
were you able to confirm only for eqtls
by real-time PCR so edging this is
adding on to what I just mentioned it
was definitely a small sample cohort
that was used for this study because the
purpose of the study was a premium
preliminary test so the only has 93 test
samples because of that we were able to
confirm only four however the trend of
the data for the rest of the target a
GTO target was very similar to that we
have seen in microarray we are but the
two PCI data was not statistically
significant to make calls one way or the
other so we do think by increasing that
number of samples that we studied we
could confirm most if not all of the
eqtl
okay wonderful wonderful all right well
thank you again so much both doctors
Tommaso dragony and her Rita Maurice
Lingam for your time today and give this
important research and explaining it all
to us we would like to also thank lab
roots and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational content before we go I'd
like to also thank you the audience for
joining us today and for your
interesting questions we didn't get time
to get to all of them today so for those
of you who submitted questions that we
didn't get to or also for the on-demand
portion of this webinar we will be
addressing those with the speakers via
the contact information that you
provided at your time of registration so
this webcast can also be viewed on
demand and lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that information
and that email with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event so
until the next time goodbye everybody
and thank you for joining us have a
great day goodbye thank you